claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude blanche
maison on le voit la russie dont qui
gèle ses missions avec l'otan après
d'énièmes accusations d'espionnage comme
le dit xavier moreau c'est une excuse et
finalement sans preuve je crois que la
première réaction c'est une réaction de
surprise parce que qui à part nous par
les spécialistes savaient que il y avait
un ambassadeur russe à l'otan et qu'il y
avait une mission diplomatique
à l'otan qui savait que en 2002 il ya vu
un sommet de l'otan avec la russie qui
avait défié de la création d'un conseil
entre la russie et l'otan qui s'est
d'ailleurs réuni à peu près chaque année
sauf pendant un an ou deux au moment de
la difficulté sur you crenn et puis
récemment à cause de la pandémie mais ce
conseil de coopération entre la russie
et l'otan s'est réuni régulièrement les
chefs militaires se voir le général
guère asimov a rencontré ses homologues
de l'otan chaque année très
régulièrement et par conséquent et bien
effectivement probablement ce canal qui
est suspendu va peut-être disparaître
c'est dommage c'est dommage parce que ça
permettait d'échanger un certain nombre
d'informations les militaires pourront
continuer d'aller recevoir sans qu'il y
ait une mission diplomatique ne serait
ce que pour éviter les conflits n'ont
souhaité les conflits de rencontre et je
pense que effectivement et bien cette
mission qui avait été réduite par le
secrétaire-général de l'otan en effet de
30 à 20 membres il y a un an et demi et
puis au printemps dernier de 20 à 10 et
maintenant dans un stade d'attrition qui
justifie sa suppression alors votre
question c'est est-ce que ils ont
espionné ou pas je n'en sais rien bien
sûr on peut dire qu'ils ont espionné
bien sûr ce qu'on peut dire aussi que
c'est une décision purement politique
générale a pris enfin des excuses mais
qui arrange tout le monde et moi ce que
je crains c'est que aujourd'hui on paie
de mots suspension mais quand en réalité
ça se fait le mot suppression qu'il
faille utiliser car ça arrangera tout le
monde ça arrangera les ultras à moscou
qui dans le fond veulent ajuster leurs
actes avec les paroles puisque l'otan
c'est le mal pourquoi sont ils auraient
des relations diplomatiques avec l'otan
il vaut mieux avoir des relations
diplomatiques et négocier avec ce qui
compte c'est à dire les états washington
et puis les états qui ont une influence
à l'intérieur de l'otan l'allemagne la
france la grande bretagne quelques
autres qui peuvent aussi avoir des
opinions divergentes plutôt qu'avec cet
organisme l'a alors certains à bruxelles
aujourd'hui disent que ça va peut-être
plus loin cette rupture des relations
avec l'otan surtout après ce que
monsieur lavrov avait dit à monsieur
borel sur l'égalité de la représentation
de l'union européenne la convocation de
la représentante de l'union européenne à
moscou est-ce que ça n'est pas un
avertissement lancé à l'union européenne
à travers cette mesure très très très
très rude de suppression de toute
représentation
est-ce que ça n'est pas un avertissement
pour dire si l'union européenne poursuit
sur la même voie en attaquant en
permanence en sanctionnant la russie et
bien et lui arrivera la même chose je ne
le crois pas je ne crois pas pour une
raison simple c'est que l'union
européenne a des relations techniques
économiques extrêmement dense avec la
russie et que le représentant permanent
de la russie auprès de l'union
européenne monsieur si georges ont un
rôle très important depuis dix ans dans
ce dans cette relation dans ce rapport
qui est probablement techniquement
indispensable craie blanche présent à ce
que cette affaire c'est pas tout
simplement une nouvelle illustration des
fortes tensions qui opposent depuis déjà
évidemment plusieurs années on le sait
la russie et les occidentaux
oui sans doute sans doute c'est
effectivement
le l'illustration de l'évolution comme
je lisais dans les années 2000 il ya une
tentative de rapprochement pendant vingt
ans il ya quand même eu à travers cette
mission à travers la mission homologue à
moscou des tentatives de trouver des
coopérations entre la russie et l'otan
ça a échoué bonds est donc maintenant ça
n'est plus possible et effectivement on
est plutôt dans une
phase malheureusement deux
confrontations sauf peut-être en ce qui
concerne les relations encore une fois
économique entre l'union européenne et
ses états membres d'une part et la
russie d'autre part alors il ya beaucoup
d'intérêts communs évidemment le dis
toujours entre la russie et les états
membres de l'union européenne evault et
intérêts communs qui sont pas seulement
économiques qui sont aussi politiques on
le voit tous les jours au proche orient
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée est
également on le verra aussi à la coop 26
dans quelques jours à glasgow on le
verra ensuite au g20 au g20 de rome où
les dirigeants se retrouveront et sur un
certain nombre de sujets doivent
nécessairement discuter et peut-être
même tenter de trouver des solutions
parce que ces sujets ne sont pas
susceptibles d'être résolue à un échelon
national même à l'échelle d'un si grand
pays qu'est la russie merci beaucoup
claude blanchet l'on nous avoir apporté
votre éclairage